[Music]
[Applause]
Dan orlovsky of the mothership ESPN
football analyst you can watch him on
NFL live weekdays at four like a smooth
segue from a vasectomy to Dan orlovsky
who joins us on the program who has who
has a lot of kids Dan uh good morning
also a vasectomy I do have a lot of kids
oh you did do a vasectomy yeah yeah true
funny story Dan so good morning great to
be with you we had we have my wife and I
have triplet Sons they're 11 right now
so we have three boys we had the three
boys we had gotten to like they were
three and a half years old just about
you could imagine having triplets three
and a half years what that span of time
was like we had just like traveled with
them and done it easily they had just
become like out of diapers all that
stuff and I was like yo we made it and
my wife and I had kind of agreed
all right we're not gonna have another
kid because our big fear was a fourth
boy and then you're always the boy of
the triplets you're the brother of the
triplets and um I had a vasectomy
planned we went on a trip to Napa with
friends ahead of a sec we plan for the
week after on the play ride home my
wife's like I don't feel good I jokingly
go like oh you're pregnant you know long
story short she was pregnant and um so
the vasectomy got delayed a year but I
finally got it done
uh a very potent Dan olowsky joining us
on the program
um speaking of which Anthony Richardson
uh certainly came away as the uh the
combine darling here I always get
nervous when we have these combine
Darlings here we've we fall in love with
numbers here yeah
um
are you all in on Anthony Richardson
yeah I have been honestly since the
first game of his that I called in
college football Dan like I called one
of his first games in college football
at Florida and I just remember being on
air going why is he not the starting
quarterback yes you know and and these
coaches like Dan Mullen I have a
tremendous amount of respect for it with
the with the transfer stuff that goes on
in the ni it's such a delicate balance
of trying to what quarterback it's no
longer just play the BET like I feel
like these they gotta massage all these
situations so much so
um but every game I called of his I was
it was just like this kid is so super
talented and then the more you heard
about him how intelligent he is how hard
he works the character all that stuff
and I just think of
kind of taking a quarterback in the
draft we know is you know good luck roll
the dice type of thing if you're rolling
the dice if you're taking your chance
you're big you're fast you're strong
you're powerful you're a natural thrower
you have great intelligence you work
really hard you've got good leadership
skills and good character where where is
the glaring oh my gosh he might fail and
I would I would say this about him
um everyone talks about the completion
percentage right 53 percent
if we broke it down I did this for Josh
Allen when he's coming out because I
thought that was a crock of crap as well
this is like two more completions a game
he's at like 61 completion percentage
two completions a game we're talking a
throwaway we're talking a missed check
down we're not talking these glaring
issues at least I don't see and while I
understand the combine pause on the
numbers we can't take it for granted
either I mean what he is is incredibly
talented
okay but you say this and you're you're
gonna look at Josh Allen but you're also
using the same kind of comparison with
Anthony Richardson Anthony Richardson
plays for Florida in the SEC and Josh
Allen lost all of his receivers there
that last year when he was at Wyoming so
I I can't I can't buy into those
comparisons between the two
Florida had very little Talent this year
I mean I'm not well they didn't have
Wyoming Talent they had better Talent
than Wyoming did Josh lost his receivers
after his his junior year there it was
but but I mean this is a kid who won new
coaching staff with Billy Napier two
um so he's learning a new system too
their number one receiver was uh I think
he was the transfer from Arizona State
uh he's not gonna go play in the NFL or
unlikely I mean I don't think he has a
single offensive I don't think Anthony
Richardson had a single offensive player
um skill wise outside of etn's little
brother that is going to be an NFL
player
well we know Josh Allen didn't have that
correct but Josh Allen wasn't playing
against
um Tennessee and Alabama and and Georgia
and I mean Josh Allen was going to play
against those guys either so that's my
like that's that well I understand that
we're talking you know like having very
little help in the SEC Conference okay
but you see the his player comp is Josh
Allen that's for me yes because that's
where I think the the path is like
that's where every and I think Josh well
what I liked about Josh coming out of
school was Josh was a very loose thrower
like it wasn't tight that's why I keep
saying he's a very natural thrower like
you know what Dan you better watch a guy
pick up a ball and throw yeah he was
born to do that I think Anthony has that
natural throwing motion okay who takes
him who should take him if you were
advising you would say
this team take him yeah I'll give you
three
um I think Indy Houston and Carolina
should very much so be entertaining
taking him I Dan I said this this
morning get up if you're an AFC team and
you don't have a really really really
good quarterback what are your chances
in the next eight years with Patrick
Josh Joe Justin Herbert Trevor Lawrence
I mean what are your chances with those
teams you got those are five I'm not
even putting two what two will becomes
Lamar Lamar situation so if you're if
you're Indian you're Houston you're
sitting there going if we don't have a
really good player that is physically
talented and can go toe-to-toe those
guys what are our chances no matter what
our roster is and then Carolina just
because I think I could put any of these
quarterbacks in Carolina then I just
think it's a tremendous situation it's
the best situation for a rookie
quarterback to go into this year so I
could put any guy at that spot
would you take Richardson over Bryce
Young
I wouldn't
uh if if I was the general manager I
wouldn't I think Bryce is a uniquely
skilled player that has all the
attributes that you look for like I
think Bryce the only way Bryce doesn't
become a very good Pro is because he
can't can't hold up and that's a real
thing for people like they they're gonna
they're gonna say yes we're okay with it
or no we're not and I understand that if
you're in the no I'm not Camp if you're
not okay with his size then you'd
probably take Anthony if you're okay
with this size because his tape is the
best and most impressive tape since Joe
Burrows tape in college he's the guy
that does the most stuff you go that's
what it looks like since Joe but are you
um a believer in product of your
environment that you're gonna can can he
hold up in Chicago or would he bet be
better served playing half of his game
indoors in Houston or Indy yeah
I mean I think any quarterback is better
served than indoors you know I I think
so I definitely would say that yeah
that's probably the benefit and like
here's the big challenge for you more
than the weather Dan is if you're an
organization that you think you can
draft and develop good offensive linemen
then then you're in a good place because
you're going to keep them clean and just
I've said this go watch his Texas game
just go watch that game go watch the
Tennessee game and watch how much he
operates in like very small spaces and
count the amount of big hits he takes in
those games I understand it's the
different level in the NFL I get all
that but just watch him move and it's
almost a little Lamar conversation a
little bit Lamar doesn't take massive
shots because of his short space just
feel and awareness Bryce has got that as
well I don't think he has to play inside
but I think it's a benefit sure
Derek Carr and the Saints it looks like
that could be close to happening your
thoughts about that
yeah I always felt like the the news
from this morning of the Derek Carr
leaning towards the Jets was a Jets kind
of gamesmanship thing hey Aaron we need
a decision here to get the ball rolling
on this I think Derek's a good player
oh you think the Jets were playing
they're they were trying to toy with uh
Aaron Rodgers yeah let's go we need we
need the time is of the essence okay
that's what I thought it was a game's
legit play because it just that seemed
that they were attached to Aaron forever
and I knew Derek you know wanted to get
a decision done
um the Saints I think of the last week
and that might it might be a little bit
of a different number because I think
they have reworked some contracts for 55
million dollars over the cap yeah so
while yes I like Derek's fit there what
does the team look like because they're
gonna have to get rid of somebody or
move money around somehow to fit his
deal under there so I just want to see
what the makeup of the team is before
sitting there and totally making a
proclamation but yes the initial
starting point is really good spot very
young offensive line in some spots that
is talented a Lobby is a superstar so
there's initially the the like of that
fit for sure yeah I get it and you're
going to the NFC South where he's
immediately the best quarterback in the
NFC South totally that's not saying too
much uh will Levis was talking a good
game he's got a cannon for an arm and he
couldn't wait to show it off uh did you
come away impressed
I I expected will to throw out really
well the only thing that I get with Will
is this and I like will I talked to will
he's obviously a Connecticut kid I'm
rooting for him
um you know like I I and I said this on
the shows last week I I would play a
couple specific clips of his game from
last year like there's a clip where he
misses some throws in my naked eye when
you watch it you're like man that's a
bad Miss and I would want to play the
play for him and just say hey tell me
about what happened on this play and I
think you'll gather so much information
from how does he see the field what is
he looking at what is he being taught
how does he process information does he
throw his receivers under the bus does
he throw his coaching under the bus
because there's some misses on tape
where you go that that looks weird and I
want to know why that ended up looking
that way
um and then I think you know for a guy
that
uh he's the a little bit different or
like the contrast of the Anthony
Richardson for me because Anthony for
six four two forties loose that's it's
kind of Josh again like for as muscular
as he is he's loose Will's a little bit
stiffer he's a little bit stockier and I
think you know that messes with his
lower half and upper half being
connected and rhythmic he's gonna have
to work really hard to gain rhythm in
his passing game super talented and can
throw it with anybody I just think you
wanted to grow with the rhythm of the
past
always good to talk to you
congratulations on the mastectomy
thanks man yeah glad I got it done
played basketball the next morning oh
you did
just tough Connecticut kids are tough
you know
I told Louis Riddick about you with your
40-yard dash he did not know that you
cheated to make yourself seem faster
when you were recruited by UConn Lewis
barely talked to me in Indy last week at
the combine so that's probably the
reason why well his combine numbers I
think he ran a 4 7 40.
Louis yeah at the combine
that's pretty good for a safety right I
don't know he's embarrassed by it he was
like do not do not bring that up cut a
leg off for four seven
what did you run when you made it a
37-yard dash
uh I ran that day I ran four eight
combined
and then at the combine they just did it
this morning I ran four nine I said I
told green I said green that was like 12
years of wearing jump souls to school
ankle weights running with the parachute
on my back just to get to four nine so
wait you ran a 4-9 and Louis Riddick
we're in a four seven two
yeah but Lewis is like 25 years older
than me not 25 maybe 15 sorry sorry Lou
yeah but his time when he ran it and
when you ran it I mean it doesn't matter
you still ran a 40 yard done you know
basically what we're getting to is Lewis
was not that fast much faster than me
yes man that's not gonna fly with Lewis
that much but you know what is so
bizarre Mina kimes ran a four six four
there's no way yeah
unbelievable yeah she passed 225 13
times and at a vertical of 34. I mean we
make fun of Meena all the time because
bro she's like guys I was such a good
Varsity soccer player
[Laughter]
good to talk to you thank you bud you're
the best bud that's Dan orlovsky you can
see him Monday through Friday NFL live
for Eastern we'll come back phone calls
coming up
back after this